now no matter how cynical you are about
the media and you ought to be pretty
cynical it may not have occurred to you
that they're literally for sale the
national news media can be bought give
them enough money and they will cover
you favorably and then they will attack
anyone who disagrees with you but that
is of course true and the stories around
FTX the crypto scam and Pfizer show that
very clearly so if you ask journalists
about this usually they seem well
ashamed because that's prostitution not
journalism but Politico which is a
left-wing political blog in Washington
is not ashamed at all if you send
Politico enough money they will run your
ads and then publish stories attacking
anyone who criticizes you without
disclosing their conflict of interest at
any point now they've been doing this
for quite some time it's an Open Secret
in Washington they're not the only ones
who do it but we just noticed because
they attacked us just the other day they
wrote a piece called why whale deaths
are dividing environmentalists and
firing up Tucker Carlson is if you have
to be some kind of right winger to care
about the Unexplained deaths of the
biggest mammals on Earth lots of whales
diets fair to ask why but shut up says
Politico
we have no idea why a dozen whales just
turned up dead in the beaches of New
Jersey does everything to do with the
construction of wind turbines off the
coast that's speculation Politico
reports probably climate change
so the story was ridiculous but what we
didn't get at first was that Politico
was paid to run it
Politico is taking a lot of money from
the corporations who manufacture and
profit from commercial wind turbines
politico's been running this ad on
behalf of the Danish wind power company
orstead it appears on political's
website it looks like a news article but
it's not oh it's an ad you wouldn't know
you're not supposed to know it's
supposed to fool you here's the headline
offshore wind the green energy Panacea
with some hurdles oh what just a few
like killing all the whales no problems
a little hurdle that's how the fake
article begins quote the EU will have to
dramatically boost its production of
renewable energy to meet its green deal
targets enter offshore wind
[Laughter]
turim Politico they're prostitutes
and they're not even ashamed so we
reached out to them today and asked well
why didn't you disclose the fact that
you're a hooker sorry that you're taking
money from offshore wind turbine
manufacturers
in your article about offshore wind
turbines
they don't want to answer that question
oh shut up
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight